when people face tragedy and challenges
or challenges in life what helps them
persevere that's a question co-authors
dr. Samson Davis and Charlie Jeter
attempt to answer that question in their
new book it's called the stuff unlock
your power to overcome challenges soar
and succeed it's published by gallery
Jeter that's an imprint of Simon &
Schuster which is a division of CBS
Charlie Jeter is president of the turn
two foundation that's a nonprofit
created by her brother yep she's related
to him baseball great Derek Jeter but we
won't hold that against her and she
joins us at the table we all love your
brother here and dr. Samson Davis he's
an emergency room doctor and New York
Times bestselling author good morning to
you both I think it's so important to
start that people understand your your
individual stories briefly about what
you've been through because Charlie was
before your 21st birthday you're being
treated for Hodgkin's lymphoma and you
tell a story of going to school and
going through cancer treatment at the
same time but this was really grueling
take us exactly what you did well at the
time I didn't feel it was too grueling
because I was young and vibrant and I
was in college just wanting to have fun
so I did six months of chemotherapy I
begged my parents and my doctor to let
me stay in school in Atlanta and I
commuted back and forth every other
Friday
it's just Sloan Kettering here yes
that's important he would school in
Atlanta and Spellman so you're going
back and forth for cancer treatment
correct when they said why don't you
give up school for a second you said no
I'm not going to do that you dr. Samson
Davis you're 17 years old you decided
that you and your friends are going to
rob drug dealers and you were the
getaway driver what did you think would
come of that being the getaway driver
thorn will get away
[Laughter]
our Cardinal got off the list but you
didn't get away so 17 you think you're
gonna go to juvenile detention and then
they find you're handcuffed and they're
set you're going to jail that's right
what I mean I changed my life I mean it
was a way of living I grew up in
inner-city struggle hardships but when I
was arrested I realized I had to change
in my life and it was up to me to sort
of decide but it wasn't with this stuff
it was something that was already inside
of me I don't have to go out and search
it or seek it out I possessed it already
it was just a matter of me activating it
and that's what you say Charlie this
stuff what does that mean the stuff that
you have it inside you well we believe
that it's an inner fortitude it's
something that you don't you're born
with it's resilience
you know grit grit exactly and it's that
a lot of people don't realize that they
have it like I didn't when we first did
this project he was telling me that I
had this inner fortitude when he knew my
story going through cancer in college so
it's really we would really like to tell
people that don't know about it that
they do have it in them I think when
people say I want to unlock that special
thing inside and so one of the helpful
pieces advice you haven't here is
writing your motivations explain how you
get that done so it's 11 elements and
writing your motivation statement is key
whatever your mantra is if you don't
have one you can use one I use the 3ds
dedication determination and discipline
these are ironclad and they are
applicable to any situation you're going
through so borrow someone's if you don't
have one or come up with your home put
it on post-its put it on your mirror
your bathroom mirror your desk doors
wherever you want to put in a house and
get you going so these 11 principles
when use can get you to unlock your
stuff and livia maximize life and the
idea is to unlock it before a tragedy
comes to you I mean that you have this
available to you just in your daily life
especially in transitions I mean like if
you're going from high school to college
or if you were tyring you want to make
sure that you're staying ahead so that
you are living your maximizer life
either in relationships or you're going
through a hardship like divorce it
doesn't have to be a tragedy you want to
make sure that you're doing your best
and their full potential and that's what
this stuff is if you didn't have the
stuff you'd be in prison with your
friends champ and pissy pillow yeah
got together because you were friends
and you're sitting on a plane and he
says we should write a book about this
and you're thinking this isn't really a
book yeah well it started out as him
wanting to write a book he used to pitch
different ideas and I was quick to tell
him anything that was wrong with his
ideas you know and in the beginning it
was he wanted to see if there was a gene
that all of these people shared and I
was like please do not make me read this
book if I'm okay yeah I'm gonna read it
cuz I'm I support you yeah but don't
make me read this book and that's when
we started to talk about having a way to
have it applicable to everybody anybody
can pick it up you guys believe
everybody has the stone gene because
there is there is some of its chemical
yeah so it is but I glad Charlie sort of
Nix that idea of using the gene you know
we discovered that these common traces
we two years we worked on this book to
find these common elements that everyone
share we had tons of stories and we
narrowed it down to 15 amazing stories
of people who overcame obstacles and
challenges and so and charlize been
doing this work for 20 years return to
foundation I have three doctors
foundations sort of the same work and
when Charlie said I have cancer and I'm
going to commute and stay in school she
caught a big deal is that I thought that
was normal she said oh everybody like
are you kidding me like who are you
kidding this is like no one does that so
you have this stuff and you've used it
in every phase of your life so it was
good for I think that's when we realized
we had something special and I and I
also said to him well if I have the
stuff then can I go on this journey with
you when you're figuring this out
because I want to know what it was that
I had so I can use it the rest of my
life you know there's no it is a really
good read and very inspiring it's how
some people see an obstacle and overcome
it and some people see an obstacle and
it devastates them your brother said
this about you who wrote the foreword
that you are one of the strongest people
he knows and we look at him as mr. tough
guy mr. strong guy and he says that
about you yeah there's a lot about you
Charlie G yeah thank thank you great
buck charlie Jeter and dr. Samson Davis
the name of the book is the stuff it's
on sale now wherever you like to buy
your books